so we're talking about women we're
talking about investing and smart
investing
uh and investing early in life um
i gotta ask you a question right out of
the gate do you think it's fair
to categorize women as saying that our
gender is just not good with money in
general no
okay is that a perception maybe because
of our rules uh
culturally
societally what's your opinion
uh well first of all all research um
that that we have shows that women are
actually much better investors than men
they tend to outperform men over the
long term part of that has to do with um
over time it appears that women seem to
trade less than men and the more that
you trade the chances are that you're
going to make a boo-boo and so
generally speaking you know there are
people who will say men or women they'll
say to me like i'm just not good at math
i can't be an investor and i'll often
say well can you add can you subtract
can you multiply can you divide okay
great we're good we can do that so i
mean whatever trope you're you're
telling yourself about either gender or
just you yourself or i'm just not good
at uh let's kind of wipe the slate clean
because none of it really matters each
of us is responsible to manage our own
financial lives and we are perfectly
capable of doing so
oh i like that um
can you say if you can even uh approach
this from
what are some of women's biggest
mistakes
financially if you can even approach it
from 30 000 feet or closer
well one of the big mistakes that women
tend to underestimate is simply their
life expectancy so women are going to
statistically live longer than men so if
you happen to be partnered with a man
who is of the same age then you're
probably going to outlive him and that
means that whether you're handling the
money or he's handling the money or the
investments you've got to look at a
longer time horizon and that longer time
horizon can really be daunting i mean
i talk to people all the time and
they'll call my podcast and they'll say
oh you know i want to retire when i'm 58
and i say great are you ready to finance
35 years of not working because that's
what we're looking at for a lot of
people and so i think the biggest
mistake is underestimating just how long
we'll live
the other problem with the way that we
approach financial planning as women
versus men is that
because women only earn on average 80
percent of what men earn
there are a lot of problems with funding
goals so for example
if you're only earning eighty percent of
what your male compatriot is earning
then you can't save enough for
retirement or as much for retirement and
you will not be in the workforce as long
maybe because you step out to have a
child and be the primary caretaker so i
think that longevity risk risk of just
pay inequality and also that idea of
taking time out of the workforce to
raise a family which can be really
important but it does put you on your
back feet when it comes to your own
financial planning so all these factors
are sort of the big picture items that i
think that many of us would just tend to
overlook as we consider our own
financial futures also too when you look
at your your social security statement
if uh generally speaking women earn less
than men over that long period of time
your social security income is not going
to be the same
as a man's at that same age in life is
that true yeah that's right i mean a
social security system is based on your
work record and if you've taken time out
of the labor force that may mean that
your work record is either not enough to
support yourself or you are ending up
claiming half of your partner's benefits
as your social security benefit which
really it just can be much lower so you
know another mistake that often that
that we'll see with um heterosexual
couples is that the the man says i'm
claiming my social security benefit at
62. i'm just done working the woman may
have been staying home and raising the
family having the primary
responsibilities at home now because her
husband is claiming at age 62 that means
her social security benefit which is
half of his
is
permanently
lower
than
for her lifetime
that's huge let's talk about and there
was a recent fidelity study of women
investors and they they covered the
gamut of age but it showed what it
revealed was that younger women 35 and
under
started investing whether it was
retirement savings uh whether it was
stocks and bonds whatever at generally
an earlier age even as young as 20 as
opposed to their older counterparts 36
and older um
who started later in life does that
surprise you
uh no because it is so much easier to
invest now than for anyone who is over
the age of 35 that there has been a real
democratization of investing and that
investing is as easy as opening up an
app on a phone and plugging in
information so i think that you know the
big advantage you have if you're under
the age of 35 is you've grown up at a
time where there are very low barriers
of entry for the world of investing
whereas you look at a typical say 55
year old woman or man that you go back
in time and you say
did you invest and i think many of us
and i'm in that cohort would be like
invest like i guess maybe through my
retirement account sorta kinda but it
wasn't so easy and i think there has
been a lot more education
and a lot more media attention on how
important it is to start early in your
investing life and you know remember
that gen z and millennials grew up and
came of age where they saw their parents
suffer potentially because they hadn't
saved enough so i think that it's a
really it's a it's a really good trend
that we see
that younger people starting sooner you
know my one caveat is that it's just so
easy to invest that i worry sometimes
that they are kind of going away from
the plain vanilla stuff that will keep
them out of trouble and you know maybe
jumping on the meme stock bandwagon or
buying crypto which is all well and good
but for your long-term investing we
still need you to get as much money as
you can in that roth ira or that roth
401k
right those nfts and all that strange
stuff that's still a little foreign to
those of us
who are in that 35 and over category
indeed
so let's talk about some of the basics
uh
about money makes money um
do you think that people have a good
good idea of concept of compound
interest and how it works well i mean
look the the the long story short about
investing is you've got uh one big goal
is you want to grow your money faster
than the pace of inflation and since
inflation's a big story right now it's
worth underscoring but that's the whole
point of investing and it's interesting
to look at say a few years ago where
people were like not really thinking
about inflation and imagine if you're
not really thinking about inflation the
benefit you have as an investor is that
your money grew by double digits over
the three years coming into 2022 and
that money grew
much faster than the pace of inflation
now that inflation has ticked up to
these 40-year highs you're kind of lucky
that you did that long-term investing
over the last few years because you've
made money in advance of this high
inflationary period so what we know
is that as investors what people need to
understand is that when you put your
money to work what you're trying to do
is look to the future
put your money to work in a basket of
different kinds of assets that could be
stocks that could be bonds that could be
commodities
and that could be real estate investment
trust and you put it all together and
over the long term what you are hoping
to do
is again over the long term at certain
times it's not going to work perfectly
you're trying to beat the rate of
inflation so that your money can grow
when your income can't grow as fast and
when you stop working and it seems like
a younger
the younger generations are a little
more savvy
to what's going on with the economy uh
in the world and inflation and just in
in general economics uh probably more so
maybe
than the 50 and older crowd maybe
and let's face it higher education
uh i was told that
it's on the other side of 50
women in the higher ed uh arena which
does that surprise you well i i think
that what's interesting is that when you
come of age can really determine a lot
of your money habits so first thing that
we know about money and investing and
your habits and where you come to this
place is that a lot of our money
instincts and habits form as early as by
the age seven so we know your family of
origin is going to either screw you up
or help you out a lot in this period
okay so you know if mom was a
spendthrift and mom and dad fought a lot
and there's going to be a lot of
fighting about money it's going to cause
you anxiety and you're gonna bring that
into your adult life i get that okay
that's why the world of psychology
exists okay
but the the interesting thing is that
when you come of age in terms of the era
can also really impact you so i have a
98 year old mother-in-law who was born
in 1923.
her idea and her ideas around investing
were really destroyed because she came
of age amid the great depression and a
world war
and so throughout her adult life you
could have told her over and over again
that she should be a long-term investor
in the stock market and she just
wouldn't be able to do it she was far
too conservative it was too difficult
for her to buy into that and i think
that that's an important thing to
remember and look at me i came of age in
the 80s when the stock market bull
market in stocks began in 1982
i come out of college it's a roaring job
market it's a roaring stock market you
have a lot of belief in this thing
called a retirement plan through work i
wasn't offered a pension it was not
something that was part of what i
thought i was losing i just thought well
i have the ability to invest in this
thing called the stock market which is
doing really well and i have more
confidence in that system fast forward
if you're a millennial and you came of
age in the dot-com boom and bust of the
early 2000s you see your parents suffer
in the housing crisis and the great
recession you live through a pandemic
you may have different thoughts about
risk you may have a different feeling
around what you can absorb and so what's
important to remember is that all these
things shape us it doesn't have to
define us but those feelings shape us
and sometimes you have to struggle
against those feelings and educate
yourself and do try to rely on some part
of this which is the historical context
but also
really being aware that that's my
history that's not the market's history
are you seeing my dog in the background
sorry about that well i'm surprised you
haven't seen mine and and our cat over
here she's had any condo
usually in and out and she usually
sleeps right on that so there you go so
yeah i'm with you there um
i wanted to ask you because you you just
covered can't afford to invest and i i
think that's probably everybody's is
that everybody's individual situation or
or
prospective or can everybody afford to
invest a little bit
look i mean if you're living paycheck to
paycheck you're not investing so let's
be honest there's a good chunk of this
country that is struggling still even if
it even in a hot job market okay
that if you are making uh you know forty
four thousand dollars a year and you're
paying a higher cost of energy a higher
cost of rent a higher cost of food and
you're just worried about making sure
your family is safe and you're paying
your bills chances are you're not
investing right now but i do think that
when you're younger there's this unique
opportunity because you probably can
scour your your monthly income and find
a few bucks to invest you probably can
figure out a way to say oh you know what
think about the pandemic i didn't do a
lot of the normal things i used to do i
was able to look at a extra you know 200
a month or maybe frankly maybe your
student loans have been paused and
they'll be paused again through the
summer maybe that extra couple hundred
bucks every month that you would have
been putting towards your student loans
you may be able to open a roth ira or
participate in your company's retirement
account and get a company match so these
are really good uh gateways to get
yourself in the habit of investing